ahora vamos a usar las ideas que vimos
en el vídeo anterior para aprender a
dibujar exponenciales muy rápidamente
vamos a realizar un par de ejemplos aquí
tenemos un circuito de ejemplo que ya he
configurado es un circuito rc aquí
tenemos mil oms y aquí tenemos un
capacitor de 2 micro farts y esta fuente
de voltaje nos proporciona un voltaje
escalón que en este caso va a comenzar
con un volts y luego bajará rápidamente
a cero cuando el tiempo sea igual a cero
y nuevamente a los 10 milisegundos
aumentará nuevamente hasta un volt y
continuará de esta manera esto podría
ser un reloj en un circuito digital o en
cualquier tipo de señal digital y
queremos encontrar cuál será el voltaje
aquí vamos a usar lo que sabemos de
nuestras formas de onda
rc para decirnos qué es lo que va a
ocurrir aquí de manera muy rápida no
necesitaremos de una computadora para
simular esto lo primero que debemos
saber es cuál es la constante rc
rc es igual a 1000 o un canal por dos
micro fans esto es igual a 2 k por micro
k es más tres micro es menos 6 así que
es 2 por 10 a la menos 3 o lo que es lo
mismo 2 milisegundos ahora puedo ir a mi
gráfica y colocar un punto a los 2
milisegundos
aquí tenemos 5 milisegundos y aquí
tenemos 2 milisegundos y rápidamente yo
sé que esta línea va a comenzar aquí
arriba y tiene que pasar por este punto
lo dibujamos más o menos así y ahora del
otro lado va a ir hacia arriba va a
comenzar aquí y va a llegar arriba 2
milisegundos después más o menos por acá
será el voltaje final de esta línea y la
dibujamos más o menos así lo mismo va a
ocurrir aquí en cuanto baje el voltaje
veo 2 milisegundos después y la línea va
a ir de aquí arriba hasta este punto
ahora vamos a hacer un poco más precisos
lo que voy a hacer es
mejor trabajo dibujando esta curva
sabemos que es aproximadamente el 37 por
ciento de nuestro voltaje total más o
menos por acá así que ahora con esto
puedo dibujar y suavizar mi curva así
del otro lado voy hacia abajo 37% y
ahora si puedo dibujar mejor mi curva
llega hasta el valor final y lo mismo
hago aquí cálculo a mi 37% la
exponencial va a pasar por aquí y luego
se va a curvar así este es mi estimado
no usamos computadora para hacer esto
como sé si estamos bien pues usa la
computadora una vez y es así como luce
la gráfica de la computadora ahora
podemos comparar ambas gráficas simular
esto en excel solamente usando las
ecuaciones para tener una respuesta
bastante precisa y pueden darse cuenta
que nuestro dibujo es bastante similar a
la simulación por computadora así que
estamos comparando esto con esto
bastante similares no está tan mal eso
me dice que mi señal de salida el
voltaje en el capacitor está siguiendo
bastante bien a la señal digital
alcanzando su punto máximo y disminuye
rápidamente vamos a resolver otro
problema más y vamos a cambiar el valor
del capacitor aquí cambiamos el valor
del capacitor a 4 micro farts aquí
seguimos teniendo un kilo así que ahora
nuestra rc va a ser igual un cada por
cuatro micros arats y esto es igual a 4
milisegundos ahora sé que la constante
de tiempo es de 4 milisegundos así que
mi dibujo de la línea va a llegar hasta
acá en el eje horizontal comienzo aquí
arriba y voy a dibujar una línea recta
lo mismo aquí voy unos 4 milisegundos
después
y ahora dibujo mi línea hacia arriba con
esta pendiente
hacemos lo mismo acá aquí avanzamos 4
milisegundos dibujamos la línea y ahora
vamos a hacer nuestro truco del 37% el
37% está más o menos por aquí así que va
a pasar por acá y aquí no sé si va a
llegar al final podría hacerlo podría no
hacerlo esta sube de la misma manera
veamos nuestro 37% que está más o menos
por aquí dibujamos esta curva y haremos
lo mismo acá el 37% está por aquí y
dibujamos nuestra curva ahora veamos la
respuesta que calculamos con la
computadora y vemos que lo hicimos
bastante bien vean esta parte de aquí
abajo vemos nuestra gráfica bastante
parecida la curva está un poquito más
arriba lo que está bien pero con esta
constante de tiempo nos podemos dar
cuenta inmediatamente de que esta curva
está en riesgo de no llegar hasta abajo
de alcanzar el valor final
desde que se le pida subir de nuevo así
que está intuición o conocimiento de la
curva exponencial nos permite conocer
estos detalles muy rápidamente podemos
hacer los cálculos manualmente incluso
podemos imaginarnos mentalmente cómo
lucirán estas gráficas el punto de
tiempo de aquí de esta línea nuestros 13
segundos después de que cae esta es una
cosa básica y la otra es este punto de
acá que es el 37% de la cantidad con la
que iniciamos esta es una buena
habilidad a desarrollar cuando tenemos
estas curvas exponenciales que las
usarán todo el tiempo si se dedican a
diseñar computadoras o cualquier otro
tipo de circuitos que tengan cambios
súbitos de voltaje como lo que tenemos
aquí